hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
entertaining game to share with you from
2002 this is when Magnus Carlson was
only 11 years old he has the white
pieces in this one and is up against Tor
gold Brunson who's 30 years older but
not as high rated
Magnus was already a monster at this
young age rated
2148 his opponent is rated 1990.
let's have a look
French defense on board
Knight D2 tarash variation
two ways you could deploy the knight in
defend E4 wise white getting in the way
the bishop you don't have to worry about
any pins with the tarash variation
Bishop B4 can now be met with C3
all right from here Knight F6 E5 if
you're playing the French defense you
must be prepared to work around a white
Pawn on E5 that's what you're signing up
for
white has space now
and continues with Knight G to F3 there
are different Arrangements white can go
forward with
the path he is choosing he's basically
saying I'm prepared to play this opening
as a Gambit
black will be able to put a lot of
attackers on D4 and white won't be able
to maintain it
so we're going to see this take shape
see pawns contribute minor pieces out
after Queen B6 how do you defend D4
one two three are on it and you only
have two defending it
first of all you don't really want to
play in this way
capturing giving up your D4 point
because now this is vulnerable it's
currently hit twice maybe a third right
around the corner
so
White's plan is to just give the pawn up
White Castles in this position
defense of this Pawn with Knight B3
that's not an option for white because
C4 would hit
and that's a fork
this specific variation is what Drew my
attention to
the pawn tension right here
and it reminded me of
who benefits by maintaining this tension
for as long as possible
and it's black in this case why
this guy right here has two options and
this guy only has one the capture
if black for instance release the
tension prior to playing Queen B6
now this would be an option to defend D4
there is no C4
but I should caution this isn't the
greatest Square for a knife
in any case black does well to maintain
the tension
Queen B6 castles black chops away in the
center
is now up a pawn
how is white compensated in what way is
white better
for being down the pawn well
the usual case has a lead in development
and also these guys stick out to me this
is usually a clown piece for the French
defense bad Bishop inside the pawn chain
okay
much more active light Square Bishop for
white
from here it's Queen A4
pinning the Knight you may say
that's not the primary function behind
Queen A4
this queen really wants to go here
black interferes with that idea Queen B4
if you're not attentive to this transfer
Queen this queen G4 move
as black let's say you play Bishop E7
this is a really irritating move to me
what are you doing about G7
you're gonna castle and allow Bishop H6
you're soon going to be down the
exchange
You're Gonna Play G6 and allow Bishop H6
how are you castling then
problems
for black if this White Queen gets to G4
so easily
so with this guy right here on E5
the Knight can't be on F6 and because
it's not an F6 it's not controlling G4
so trying to find some way to get this
queen to G4
would be great
Queen functions really well Queen on G4
Pawn on E5
this Arrangement is very good I should
go one step further this Arrangement
Queen Knight and pawn are fantastic
this guy probably wants some credit too
all right
in the game it's Queen B4 white says no
way I'm down the pawn cannot afford a
queen exchange stop bothering me
all right those a lot of Queen moves in
this game Queen A4
Queen C2 Queen E2 what is black doing
black went Queen B4 Queen C5
white will soon grab an additional Tempo
against this queen she is after all on
an only open file
the bishop maybe a rook can bother the
queen
alright from here now we have Bishop E7
Bishop E3 Queen A5 Bishop G5
the computer is not a fan of this move
black doesn't reply in the best way to
it
in this game the queen
is still excited she moves yet again
goes back home
this isn't a good move considered better
is to throw a rook on an open file
why is this not a good move well
it's pointing out that black can take on
G5 and then
play H6 now
I believe when you're playing as black
you maybe don't want to even see this
Knight get here because then all of a
sudden you have to maybe deal with the
queen getting to H5 for instance
so let's see what that looks like if
black played here
here and then H6 the Knight maybe you
might be thinking to yourself as black
maybe it doesn't have to move maybe the
queen could go here pin the pawn and
threaten
you know really bad stuff on F7 not
quite mate but
black would have a good move in this
position with Knight takes E5 but maybe
this specific line wasn't calculated by
black
in any case
black is not so quick to invite this
Knight onto the G5 Square
this this H6 I should know if the Knight
immediately falls back here black could
continue with Knight C5 Bishop D7
looking for a skewer
okay
in this game the queen goes back home
Queen E3
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes Bishop
Queen E7 Rook 8 to C1
and H6 so this is the big moment in the
game
throw this to you as a pop quiz your
knight is under Fire
how would you react to Black's last move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video
and see what you come up with
okay are you ready for this one
talk about brilliant
board vision
how easy it may be to be fixated on this
G5 Square you ready for this star move
Queen takes A7
almost just seems like it's um
those of you who are familiar with chat
GPT you know recommending some wild
looking move that seems to make no sense
straight away okay this is the best move
in the position to take the A7 Pawn
what is going on here well the reply to
this move is Rook B8
what's happening though if you take the
queen
White's gonna win a piece
with Rook takes Bishop
Queen has to block
we take the queen
we're not done yet we take the pawn with
check
we take the Rook finally
we're done with that continuation this
combination and lights up a light Square
Bishop after all of it
so the queen on A7 if you take her
you're going to be down a piece soon
enough
so what's tried in this game is
Rook to B8
and now comes Queen takes Rook
Knight takes Queen
Rook takes Bishop check
Rook takes Rook if this Knight Falls
this night Falls
black saves the night white saves the
night
Where Do We Stand what's the imbalance
it's two Rooks and a bishop versus a
queen
white is completely winning this was the
winning shot excellent board vision
you're attacked on the king side and
then a bolt out of the blue Queen takes
a seven
from here it's just a matter of
technique to convert
pinning the Knight
and now a look at this monster we're
gonna see some
tricks for team white soon enough with
this guy on E5 supported with the Rook
white has the flight Square now Rook is
hit defended
this guy's defended as well and now
some fancy move
Rook to d8
and when you play this you need to need
to know that you have a good answer to
Queen B5 there is only one good move
here and that is to first save The Rook
with check
now
just I should quickly point out taking
the Rook is met with Knight takes C6 and
you get the queen
get that fork
from here Queen B5 Rook D7 check
King goes back and now Rook E4 not a
purely defensive move
white is on this and also nearby there
is a two move combo
two moves out from getting to the eighth
rank
how do you deal with that
in the game it's C5
if you don't defend this Pawn the pawn
is just going to be one and white will
be perfectly coordinated no problems
that's the primary thing you must do as
white playing against the queen make
sure your pieces are all defended
not subjected to any crazy Forks
in this game it is C5 there's no longer
pressure on the Knight which now allows
White to play Rook F4
don't have to babysit the Knight how are
you defending this
you must give up the queen for
The Rook at this stage otherwise you're
going to be getting checkmated
Queen takes Rook Knight takes Queen
takes Knight and this one goes no
further black actually made his last
move and then threw in the towel
completely dead position of course
wiping up The Rook
we can stop this guy many ways we have a
past Pawn of Our Own
dead position completely winning for
team white beautiful tactical shot there
Queen takes A7 I did not see that one
coming myself when I initially went
through this game
really wild stuff excellent board Vision
at this young
age team Carlson
11 year old Carlson finding that that's
really impressive
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe check a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
foreign